we're told that nieria earns 75 for four
hours of tutoring how much does nieria
earn for one hour of tutoring pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
well the key here is 75 dollars for four
hours of tutoring and there's a couple
of ways you could think about it the
ratio here is 75 dollars for every four
hours so if you wanted one hour of
tutoring well it's just going to be
one-fourth of the 75 dollars or you
could just take 75 and divide by 4.
another way you could think about it you
could say
the area gets 75
dollars
for every
4
hours
which is another way of saying
that nieria is going to earn 75 divided
by 4
dollars
per
hour
so really we just have to figure out
what 75 divided by 4 is so let's do a
little bit of long division
so four goes into seven one times one
times four is four we're going to
subtract seven minus four is three
bring down that five four goes into 35
eight times 8 times 4 is 32 i will
subtract again i get a 3.
well now i'm going to get some decimals
here so let me
bring down a 0. 4 goes into 30 7 times
seven times four is twenty-eight
subtract and then i get a two bring down
another zero
four goes into twenty five times five
times four is twenty and i am done no
more remainder here so we get that
nieria earns 18.75
dollars
dollars
per
hour or you can just say that she makes
18.75
per hour